what Zakia some scholars say that
smoking is haram I'd like to know what's
your opinion and does smoking invalidate
the fast as far as smoking is concerned
several years before when science had an
advantage that far
most of the scholars used to say that
smoking is makrooh based in hadith omens
are seldom which mentions a Buhari more
in number one in the book of aden hadith
number eight five five yet the Prophet
said that anyone who eats garlic or
onion they should stay away from us and
stay away from the mosque preferred said
that you know don't come to the mosque
after having garlic onion because this
bad breath when you are smoking the
breath is worse then onion or garlic so
based on this hadith therefore garlic in
and it does become harm it was makrooh
so based on this hadith scholars give
the fatwa that smoking is macro but now
after science has advanced we have come
to know that smoking is nothing but it's
a slow poisoning tobacco in any form
rather than smoking cigarettes whether
BD with the tobacco and hookah whether
chewing tobacco all forms of tobacco
contains nicotine entire and we know
it's nothing but slow poisoning that is
the reason most of the non-muslims also
they agree that smoking is haram not
only the Muslim world even the
non-muslim that is the reason they put a
statutory warning on the cigarette packs
they put a stereo dari warning saying
cigarette smoking is injurious to health
or in some countries it mentioned
general surgeons warning or surgeon
general's warning smoking is injurious
to health and anyone gives the ad
whether than newspaper in the magazine
or television it is complicity that they
have to highlight the statement smoking
is injurious to health some of the
Muslim world even the non-muslim world
agrees that smoking is nothing but slow
poison and today around statistics the
world
Health Organisation says that every year
more than four million people die only
because of smoking and if you count the
other forms of tobacco it will be much
more
and today medical science tells us and
even I had learnt when I'll doing my
medicine the medical college that more
than 90% of the lung cancer deaths only
due to smoking where the cigarette or
media whatever it is 25 percent of the
cardiovascular deaths only because of
smoking 70 to 75 percent of bronchitis
and related deaths only because of
smoking smoking is nothing but snow
poison it blackens your lips locking the
gums your fingertips it damages your
lips
the damages Suffolk is it damages your
stomach and it can cause constipation it
can cause loss of appetite
it can cause loss of libido a sexual
power get suppress it can cause immunity
to the drugs you take and it reduces the
defence of your body and you can only
give a talk on why smoking is around and
I'm given the talk on dry tea laws in
Islam and I've covered this topic in
detail time doesn't permit mere but
based on all these various research
there are today more than 400 fatwas the
majority of the scholars they agree
they're smoking a salam and all form of
tobacco is haram there may be certain
squad of the certain countries including
this country where I come from India
they say it is Meru yet but most of the
scholars otherwise thought the world
majority of them they agree that smoking
is haram Allah says in the Quran in
surah Araf chapter number 7 verse 157
that you follow the Prophet the
unlettered prophet was mentioned in your
law and scriptures and further it says
that this prophet asked you to do things
which are good for you tie up for you so
take what he gives it to you what is
lawful and good any prohibits things
which are these things which are
unlawful things with a bet for you so
what our prophet gives what he gives you
which is good take any prohibits the
things which are
is unlawful you have to abstain from it
this is Allah and Allah says in the
Quran in surah Baqarah chap number two
was the 195 make not your own hands to
cause of your own destruction indicating
they do not clean your own self because
mocking is nothing worse Oh poisoning it
comes on this category something like
suicide
slow poisoning every puff you take we
reduce your life so based on this there
are more than 400 fatwa saying that
smoking is around and furthermore this
is another major reason why Haram
furthermore Allah says in the Quran in
surah Araf chapter number 7 verse 31 eat
and drink would not be extravagant Allah
says in surah chapter number 17 verse
number 26 27 that did not be extravagant
do not be a spendthrift verily a person
who the spendthrift is a rather of the
Satan is a brother of the devil and we
know that when we smoke in nothing but
extravagance it is nothing but taking a
pound note or a few pounds or taking a
dollar note the green dollar bill or a
pound and lighting up with fire when we
smoke when we let this figure it is
nothing but burning money whether it be
rupees whether it be dollar whether it
be pounds whether it be realized it's
nothing but extravagance which is Haram
in Islam and you can give a list of
reasons why it's Haram but just took a
shot one more reason that you cannot
harm your own neighbor you cannot harm
your own brother
and in smoking when you exhale out the
smoke it causes more damage pure
neighbor passive smoking is more
dangerous than active smoking and the
person who smokes when he exit is out if
the person was a neighbor in here is the
smoke it causes more damage to him and
the person who smokes that is in many
countries like Singapore that are the
banned smoking in public places and your
personal house you can do it in public
places in government places smoking has
been meant so based on this it's Haram
so smoking is Haram as far as the second
part of the question is concerned that
the smoking invalidate the fast normally
when a person smokes this more goes into
the lung but there are some other
particles also that go into the stomach
so when we smoke besides the smoke going
to the lungs it also goes into the
stomach and there are some particular
there are some vegetable things so all
the scholars unanimously agree that
smoking does break the fast it invaded
the fast so when you are smoking besides
a person breaking the fast he's even
doing a sin and that reduces the reward
and many people who are changed smokers
they don't smoke during fasting but the
moment the fast ends after if that the
dick puffs and the he bought smoking the
full night and Astra fula this again
defeats the purpose of fasting
increasing a Toccoa
and if a person can abstain from dawn to
dusk from the beginning of dawn to
sunset very well I can abstain from
smoking from the cradle to the grave so
it's my advice the chain smoker from tan
is a very good time where they can
really stop smoking and that will be a
permanent part in the life in Sharla for
the future